hey everyone and welcome to what was
that with Gabe Sanchez as the midterm
election races intensify so are Trump's
rallies and if you thought Trump's other
rallies were bizarre just wait till you
hear this fascist Q Anon word vomit
[Music]
like most of Trump's rallies Trump will
invite guest speakers to spread hate and
lies from their fascist soapbox he's the
one we elected in 2016. the one we
re-elected in 2020 who won the election
by the way oh yeah he won he did that's
Donald J Trump and just like a toxic ex
who can't move on Margaret Taylor green
has made her whole personality about
Trump and the 2020 election well that
and being anti-semitic which makes sense
considering the theme of this rally and
since the rally took place in Ohio
another guest speaker was sexual abuse
accomplice Jim Jordan which is
surprising considering his past attempts
at speaking uh I'd have to go I I I
spoke with him that day after I think
after I don't know if I spoke with him
in the morning or not and I I just don't
know uh I'd have to go back and I I mean
I don't I don't I don't know uh though
that when when those conversations
happen but Jim Jordan got on his fashion
soapbox and really tried his hardest
well sorta if only someone had give him
a soapbox to stand on anyway let's get
to Trump's speech I bet you're wondering
how we started the rally murder shooting
stabbings rapes carjackings or
skyrocketing well I guess we shouldn't
be surprised that Trump immediately
resorted to fear-mongering also can we
just focus on the Newsmax Chiron for
just a sec Trump is on stage trying to
scare supporters into having a heart
attack while Newsmax is trying to sell
them a hard test let's see what else
Trump had to say our country is being
invaded it's an invasion by millions of
illegal aliens from all over the planet
and it's this type of hateful racist and
xenophobic rhetoric that Trump uses to
drive a wedge between Americans and
everyone else AKA if you ain't white you
ain't right and it's echoed even further
by right-wing entertainers like cucker I
mean a Tucker Carlson in political terms
this policy is called the Great
replacement the replacement of Legacy
Americans with more obedient people from
Faraway countries this US versus them
mentality is nothing more than a racist
conspiracy theory that motivates Mass
Shooters to go out and solve an
imaginary problem that Republicans have
created especially when you have Trump
talking about Caravans of drug dealers
rapists and murderers pouring into our
country say well you won't take these
horrible convicts and other people that
you released into our country illegally
and you put them in Caravans I came up
with that term by the way that was my
term like fake news and lots of other
terms we came up with uh I think
Webster's Dictionary might want to have
a word speaking of making stuff up in
the Border Trump claims that he
completed the border wall and completely
finished our original border wall plan
it was all done and then we said let's
add 200 200 miles more this is just flat
out wrong Trump was never close to
finishing the border wall only 80 miles
of newberries were built with the rest
being replacement structures and now at
least a quarter billion dollars worth of
Trump's impenetrable and Powerful wall
is just a pile of rusting steel not to
mention parts of the wall along the
Arizona border were torn apart by a
Summer monsoon the monsoon literally
blew floodgates off their hinges and
don't even get me started on Trump
trying to Lobby 1.2 to a billion dollars
for the build the wall scam yeah the
very same one that Steve Bannon was
indicted for fraud money laundering and
conspiracy but you know just a criminal
helping out a fellow criminal and
speaking of criminals Trump had this to
say about drug dealers and human
traffickers and I'm calling for the
death penalty for drug dealers and human
traffickers Wow first off that is really
like really bad news for Trump's Sundown
Junior and second off Trump just called
for the death penalty of Texas governor
Greg Abbott and Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis Abbott and DeSantis are turning
innocent migrants into Political pawns
by trafficking them to Blue States as a
way to own the libs so now Bear County
Sheriff Javier Salazar has launched a
criminal investigation into Ron DeSantis
for flying 48 migrants from San Antonio
to Martha's Vineyard and not only that
but the migrants who were flown to
Martha's Vineyard have now filed a
class-action lawsuit against Ron
DeSantis and other Florida officials oh
I almost forgot under Trump's proposed
policy Matt Gates would also get the
death penalty which makes Matt Gates
asking Trump for a pardon for sex
trafficking a little awkward
during the rally Trump took an
opportunity to whine about being the
victim claiming that the January 6
Witnesses are being blackmailed by the
government to say very bad things about
Trump the unhinged persecution of me and
my staff and they go into people that
know me and they threaten them with jail
time unless you say something bad about
Trump they're threatening them these
people are sick and like all of Trump's
claims they are never backed up with any
evidence but Maga doesn't care they will
attack when ordered the same way they
did on January 6th most recently members
of the 1776 restoration movement flooded
the veterans Suicide Hotline with bogus
calls demanding the release of January 6
rioters and make no mistake this
disgusting stunt pulled by fake treats
is a direct result of Trump's speech and
in the same way Trump attacks migrants
he labels anyone who isn't Maga as a
threat here is targeting JD Vance's
opponent Tim Ryan he recently called on
his supporters to kill
kill the mega movement he wanted to kill
did you see that we have to kill Mega
kill Maga we better be careful and we
better be strong and we better be smart
because these people are coming after
you and it's not going to be good when
it comes to Trump's rallies he's usually
there to brag and talk about himself but
this time he was there to support JD
Vance but this is also interesting
because JD Vance had previously said
that Trump was America's Hitler JD Vance
is going to clinch the Senate yeah he
said some bad things about me but that
was before he knew me and then he fell
in love at least Trump got JD Vance's
name right this time I mean not like in
May when Trump tried to endorse JD Vance
over Josh Mandel but instead he endorsed
someone named JP or JD Mandel that's
what they're waiting for they're waiting
for One race you know we've endorsed Dr
Oz we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and they say Biden is
the one with cognitive issues oh and in
case anyone forgot about the infamous P
tape Trump is here to remind you in the
phony steel dossier it was all phony how
would you like to be me and go home and
explain that one to my wife
darling it wasn't true I swear it was it
remember that one with the hookers from
Russia you're right what was that me
myself and I got a sneak peek of the
Trump P tape and uh after watching I
immediately did this
and as soon as my eyes were covered I
was able to watch the rest of trump
speech which took an alt-right turn into
Q Anon territory and a department of
justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a president who is
cognitively impaired and in no condition
to lead our country wait what was that
and in no condition to lead our country
okay not sure if you heard that song
playing underneath Trump's speech but
that is the Q Anon theme song wwg one
wga which stands for where we go on we
go all Trump is now fully embracing Q
Anon and in response his magical raised
their hands to him in a weird salute
with a number one actually hold on I've
seen this before zoom in let's enhance
cross analyze with archive photo
oh my God just as I suspected Mac is
just a bunch of Nazis and Trump is
riling them up in order to incite more
violence if he doesn't get his way
here's the thing Trump should probably
Focus Less on the Nazi Q Anon rallies
and more on the pressing issues like New
York attorney general Leticia James
filing a 250 million lawsuit against
Trump and his crime family for allegedly
defrauding lenders or the classified
documents case at Mar-A-Lago or the
Georgia elections case or I don't know a
handful of other lawsuits that are
coming his way just a thought well I'm
Gabe Sanchez and this has been what was
that
foreign
[Music]